the fastest way to change your habits is
to change your environment you ever
notice how when you're in a different
environment maybe you go on vacation
maybe you go to an event or seminar you
start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well it's
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that's why you do
it too and so if you want to be able to
switch your habits quickly you change
your environment